the number one lesson I could offer you
where your work is concerned is this I
think I feel feel fear quite strongly so
it's not as though I just have the
absence of fear I've I feel it quite
strongly
you cannot invent and pioneer if you
cannot accept failure want to be happy
build a life not just a business
hey seven Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you as
well you've got Michael Jordan level
talent at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn some of
the best rules of success from this
decade enjoy
okay let's kick it off with real number
one act despite fear with Elon Musk or
unusually fearless and willing to go in
the face of other people telling you
something that's crazy and I know a lot
of pretty crazy people you still stand
out where does that come from or how do
you think about making a decision when
everyone tells you this is a crazy idea
where do you get the internal strength
to do that
I'm office well I'd say I actually think
I feel feel fear quite strongly so it's
not as though I just have the absence of
fear I've I feel it quite strongly but
there are times when if something is
important enough you believe it enough
that you do you do it in spite of the
fear so speaking of important things
like people shouldn't think III I should
if you should think well I feel fear
about this and therefore I shouldn't do
it it's normal to be to feel fear like
you'd have to definitely something
mentally wrong you shouldn't feel fear
so you just feel it and let the
importance of it drive you to do it
anyway yeah you know actually we're
something that can be helpful as
fatalism some degree if you just think
if you just accept the probabilities
then that diminishes fear so my starting
SpaceX I thought the odds of success
were less than 10% and I just accepted
that actually probably I would just lose
lose everything but that maybe would
make some progress if we could just move
the ball forward even if we died maybe
some other company could pick up the
baton and move and keep moving it
forward so that were still do some good
yeah same with Tesla I thought your odds
of a car company succeeding were
extremely low rule number two
master your craft with
/ Winfrey and number one lesson I could
offer you where your work is concerned
is this becomes so skilled so vigilant
so flat-out fantastic at what you do
that your talent cannot be dismissed
stop comparing yourself to other people
[Applause]
you're only on this planet to be you not
someone else's imitation of you I had to
learn that the hard way on the air live
anchoring the news one night in my 20s
when I first started broadcasting I was
19
moved to an anchor by the time I was 20
and I was just pretending to be Barbara
Walker Walters I was just trying to talk
like Barbara act like Bravo Barbara hold
my legs like Barbara and I was on the
air and I hadn't read the copy fully and
I called Canada Canada and I did that on
the air I crack myself up because I
thought Barbara would never call Canada
Canada and that little break through
that little crack that little moment
that I stopped pretending allowed the
real me to come through your life
journey is about learning to become more
of who you are and fulfilling the
highest truest expression of yourself as
a human being that's why you're here
rule number three experience more with
Jeff Bezos you cannot invent and pioneer
if you cannot accept failure its you to
invent you need to experiment and if
it's if you know in advance that it's
going to work it is not an experiment
and so that's a very important thing you
know it's these they're inseparable
twins failure and invention it's so you
have to be willing to do that
it's embarrassing to fail you know it's
always embarrassing to fail but you have
to say no that's not how this works if I
said to you you have a 10% chance of a
particular decision a 10% chance of a
100x return you should take that bet
every time but you're still gonna be
wrong nine out of ten times and it's
gonna feel bad nine out of ten times and
in in in with technology the outcomes
the results can be very long tailed they
it's very the payoff is can be very
asymmetric which is why you should do so
much experimentation
you know pee buddy knows that if you
swing for the fences you hit more home
runs which should also strike out more
but with the baseball that analogy
doesn't go far enough because with
baseball no matter how well you connect
with the ball you can only get four runs
the success is capped at four runs but
in business every once in a while you
step up to the plate you hit the ball so
hard you get a thousand runs and so when
that when you have that kind of
asymmetric payoff and you know one at
one at back and get you a thousand runs
it encourages you to experiment more
it's the right business decision to
experiment more it's also better for
your customers customers like the
successful experiments rule number four
find your obsession with Bill Gates
computers when I was young were super
expensive and my friend Paul Allen and I
actually snuck in two places at the
University of Washington where they had
computers that weren't being used at
night and so we were fascinated by what
the computer could do but very few
people are getting exposure we had to go
out of our way and we were lucky that we
did it all and so then when the idea of
moving the computer onto a chip that
Intel would make and that would make the
computer literally millions of times
cheaper than the ones we were using so
both more powerful and available to
people on a personal level then the idea
of okay it would be very different the
software you needed the way the industry
would work we were super lucky to be
there when that was happening so what
did your family think did they say
there's something wrong with this young
man he wants to just do computers they
knew I was obsessed with computers that
I would skip athletics that I'd go in
overnight that I you know leave the
house sometimes when they prefer I
wouldn't go work at night on these
things and so it was kind of considered
a little strange and the big moment was
when I said instead of going to part of
my senior year that I wanted to go work
for company writing software so they
were great about allowing that to be my
hobby also if you want to have more
confidence check out my to 54 series
they're free the link to join under
description below there are times when
something is important enough you
believe in it enough that you do you do
it in spite of fear you really have to
believe the Internet's going to be
mainstream a lot of people are gonna get
out there and use it become so skilled
so vigilant so flat-out fantastic at
what you do that your talent cannot be
dismissed rule number five conquer your
fears with Will Smith somebody once said
that the chains of heaven are too light
to be felt until they're too heavy to be
broken I have been terrified of public
speaking I couldn't do it I throw up
and I know if I didn't cure it then they
never jury and so I so I'd ad in the
paper for the Dale Carnegie horse which
worked on developing your ability to
speak in public and I went down there be
a good mile as the thing I think as a
puppy fail what a puppy way they made us
all these crazy things to get out of
ourselves and so we stood on tables and
did all kinds of things
I hadn't have done that my whole life
would have been different so in my
office you will not see the degree I got
from the University of Nebraska you'll
not see the master's degree I got from
Columbia University but you'll see the
little award certificate I got from the
Dale Carnegie course rule number six get
honest with yourself with Mel Robbins
I've always wanted a six pack and I
don't have it and I don't know and I've
never had it and when I I finally
stopped complaining about it when I got
honest about what it was gonna require
I'm dead serious dead serious about this
at my you know at forty nine with my
affinity for alcohol and my love of
carbs and my distaste for exercise I
have a small problem on my hands if I
want a six-pack so if you were to go
forward right and think okay well if a
year from now I had a six-pack what
would what would that actually what
would my day-to-day life look like
and you can get very clear that you're
not committed to that and then you can
stop beating yourself up for this you
never intend on doing what I realized is
I can spend four minutes a day in a
hotel room or in my bedroom doing planks
and my arms look great and everybody
else will think the rest of my body is
in shape it works like a charm
so you might want to get honest with
yourself I can instead of doing this be
a billionaire or do this
do you really because you can make it
happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make money
but you're gonna have to roll the clock
forward just a year and say okay if I'm
able to put $1,000 a month against my
debt I'm able to make X amount of
dollars a month I'm able to put X amount
of dollars in savings what do I need to
be doing a year from now to make that
happen and what are those habits that
are there a year from now that I don't
have right now and then roll yourself
back to this moment just like I
explained with exercise do I actually
not want to have a Manhattan tonight
nope did I want to go to the gym today
nope
did I am I willing to not eat what I ate
for but nope
and my Willa I did my 4 minutes my arms
are looking really good but so bring it
back and then you will have the formula
for pivoting at any moment
you time travel forward a year you
investigate the patterns that you have
that are giving you the result that you
want and then you back your ass up to
right here right now and you decide am I
willing to do this now if I'm willing
then 5 4 3 2 1 through all the excuses
that are gonna be there when you're
trying to override your operating system
that's how you do it or you have the
reality check like I had which is okay
but I just like the [ __ ] I don't intend
on changing so why don't we get this off
the plate and let's focus on the things
that I am actually committed to rule
number seven never give up with Jack Ma
I never thought we could survive for 18
years and then we made it the only thing
that today we should do is share the
experience and know-how
especially share the mistakes suffers
with others my thinking is that you guys
remember if you want to be successful
learn from the other people's mistakes
don't learn from the successful stories
successful stories they make don't
listen to that there are a lot of
reasons behind it just like god I
remember the first time a Harvard
Business School came to us say Jack we
want to write a case study for you yes
years 2001
a 2000 they came they spent one week and
they write a report and I read no I said
this is not me and this is this is you
as a no this is not us
he said this is you so they make up his
sign and they case study go up and
instead to teaching love universities
the next five years they invite you need
to go to the case study and they always
find a competitor of my company and F
after every case that case study Ali
Papa would die that company will succeed
all the students are Greek and actually
every five years all the competitive
I wish to survive so how can you study
this kind of a success of a star learn
from the mistakes the other people no
matter how smart you are you will
encounter these mistakes you learn from
mistakes not because you will be able to
avoid mistakes you were able to when
these mistakes come this suffer comes
you know how to deal with it how to face
it
I write the book I want to write if I if
I want if I can
it's a re Bubber 1001 mistake this is
the most rational things rule number
eight break the rules with simon Sinek
we tell you a story so a friend of mine
and I we went for a run in Central Park
the Roadrunners organisation on the
weekends they host races and it's very
common at the end of the race they'll
have a sponsor who will give away
something apples or bagels or something
and on this particular day when we got
to the end of the run there were some
free bagels and they had picnic tables
set up and on one side was a group of
volunteers on the table were boxes of
bagels and on the other side was a long
line of runners waiting to get their
free bagel so I said to my friend let's
let's get a bagel and he looked at me
and said that lines too long and I said
free bagel and he said I don't want to
wait in line and I was like free bagel
and he says not let's it's too long and
that's when I realized that there's two
ways to see the world some people see
the thing that they want and some people
see the thing that prevents them from
getting the thing that they want I could
only see the bagels
he could only see the line and so I
walked up to the line I leaned in
between two people put my hand in the
box and pulled out two bagels and no one
get mad at me because the rule is you
can go after whatever you want
you just cannot deny anyone else to go
after whatever they want
now I had to sacrifice choice I didn't
get to choose which bagel I got I got
whatever I pulled out but I didn't have
to wait in line so the point is is you
don't have to wait in line you don't
have to do it the way everybody else has
done it you can do it your way you can
break the rules you just can't get in
the way of somebody else getting what
they want that's rule number one
rule number nine find fulfillment with
Tony Robbins fulfillment is an art
what's going to fulfill you is
differently a person actually you're not
gonna learn that from anybody else you
got to find it because success without
fulfillment is the ultimate failure and
I get those phone calls all the time for
the multi billionaire entrepreneur or
politician or business person or person
just one their Academy Award and they're
depressed and they can't tell anybody
because they got all their goals but
they're not fulfilled because they
really don't have that sense of meaning
in their life they went for something
and they got it they achieved and if you
doubt this one I'm saying is relevant to
you or us or anyone just think about
about a year and what a month ago we
lost what I consider be a national
treasure robbing wipes how many of you
loved robbing wipes look around the room
keep the hands up look and most of you
didn't know almost anywhere you go in
the world people of Robin Williams by
the way was he graded achievement oh my
god that guy he said you want to make
become a great comedian he did that I
want to make the world laugh he did I
want to make my own TV show he did I
wanted the number one TV show he did it
I want to make movies he did I want an
Academy Award for not being funny not
his skill set drama and he did it I want
a beautiful feeling he did it and then
he hung himself make everybody happy but
yourself not a good plan so if I had a
gift to give you it would be maybe make
a different decision and a decision is
that no matter what happens in your life
you're gonna live in a beautiful state a
beautiful state and that could be happy
that could be grateful that could be
being generous those are all beautiful
states aren't they it could be
various it could be fun it could be
playful you're not limited to one state
but it's different than suffering and
most people suffering and all suffering
I've ever seen I traveled 100 countries
I've dealt with presence of countries
and you know presidents of businesses
CEOs I've dealt with people in prison
I've dealt with you name it average
people suffering always comes picture
obsessed about something related to you
you can only be depressed if you're
focusing on yourself so now I'm
depressed cuz my kids and and they're
not doing well no you're depressed cuz
you feel you've failed your kids it's
about you it's about how you think you
what you should have done or shouldn't
have done or what someone did to you or
didn't do to you in the past or the
future which don't even exist so I have
a simple goal my goal is help people
make a decision that says I don't know
what's gonna happen you might get a
divorce even though you don't think so
you might find a family of your family
with cancer you might have your house
get burned down I have a tornado go by
and if you live in the same place it
happens every two years and you move
back we should talk but some people seem
to do that for some reason you can't
control those things I can't control
those things I don't want those to
happen to you or anybody I love or
anybody who's even a stranger to me but
they're going to happen true not
positive thinking both just the truth so
if that's gonna happen I say make a
decision now that says I'm gonna live in
a beautiful state and I'm gonna find
beauty and whatever Life brings me cuz
life is too short not to and rule number
10 the last one before a very special
bonus clip is stop doing wrong things
with Jordan Peterson stop doing the
things that you know are wrong that you
could stop doing right so it's it's a
fairly it's a fairly limited attempt
first of all we're not gonna say that
you know what the good is or what the
truth is in any ultimate sense but we
will presume that there are things that
you're doing that for one reason or
another you know are not in your best
interests there's something about them
that you just know you should stop there
are kind of self-evident to you other
things you're gonna be doubtful about
you're not gonna know which way is up
and which way is down but there are
things that you're doing that you know
you shouldn't do now some of those you
won't stop doing for whatever reason you
don't have the discipline or maybe
there's a secondary payoff or you don't
believe it's necessary
too much of a sacrifice er you're angry
or resentful or or afraid who knows
so forget about those for now but
there's another subset that you could
stop doing it might be little thing well
that's fine
stop doing it and see what happens and
what will happen is your vision will
clear a little bit and then something
else will pop up in your field of
apprehension that you will also know you
should stop doing and that you could
stop doing because you've strengthened
yourself a bit by stopping doing the
particulars stupid thing that you were
doing before that just puts you together
a little bit more and you could do that
repeatedly for for an indefinite period
of time and and you know that doesn't
necessarily mean that you're going to
ever be able to formulate a clear and
final picture of what constitutes the
truth and the good but it does mean that
you'll be able to continually move away
from what's untruth and what's bad and
you know well that's not a bad start now
I have a special bonus clip from Robert
Kiyosaki on how to master sales that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching a
video to taking action here yeah
question number one what are the wrong
things that you need to stop doing
number two what does fulfillment look
like for you and number three where do
you need to get more honest with
yourself and if you made it this far in
a video I want to celebrate you give me
a hashtag believe down the comments as
well I always say the number one skill
of an entrepreneur ability to sell or
communicate number one because sales
equals income so if your sales are down
your incomes down but it's not just
selling your customer you got to sell
your employees that's really tough you
know and then next is selling my
investors so I'm selling investors and
selling employees and selling customers
and I'm selling myself you know I got to
talk myself into I don't have the day I
don't have the pleasure of being down
entrepreneurs gotta be up because if
you're down employees no customers no at
the market knows it
so number one is sales but when you look
at the big picture there's three things
an entrepreneur must learn number one is
PR and what you're talking about is PR
the other the other day Fox News
interviewed me to find out if I would
endorse my friend Donald Trump for
president you know much that's worth you
know they they call branded us
Kiyosaki rich dad and Trump yeah that's
incredibly priceless you know so getting
PR is a number one skill under that is
marketing and marketing does is like
advertising they want to set the
customer up to get ready to buy oh yeah
oh yeah I saw that key I had I want to
buy a Kia I want to buy some land you
know I want to buy you this so the
customer is now primed to buy it that's
marking his job then the last thing is a
sale so if you've done a really good job
on PR then you've done a great job on
marketing the sale is like that you know
they walk in they buy but if you have no
PR and you have no marketing you have to
pound pound hard clothes a lot mr.
customer you know you know today's
changing business environment you know
you should buy my insurance you know and
people today hate sales pitches more
than ever before so the number one sales
job of a true entrepreneur is develop
your ability to get PR I'll say it again
most entrepreneurs are not good at sales
they're horrible at mark and they have
no idea what it is and they can't get
any PR and so they struggle and again
sales equals incomes they crash
if you want to learn the 10 Universal
skills that are hard to learn but will
pay off forever
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there every
morning I go for a run that's the first
thing I do every morning haven't taken a
day off of running since December 2016